Buckingham Palace have now confirmed
that the Duke of Sussex Harry will
attend the coronation they sent out a
statement saying that Buckingham Palace
is pleased to confirm that the Duke of
Sussex will attend the coronation
service at Westminster Abbey which is
happening on the 6th of May
The Duchess of Sussex Megan will remain
in California with Prince Archie and
Princess lillibet so that's just saying
who's coming and who isn't it's not
saying who was invited and who wasn't
but again
the Duke of Sussex there you go
Buckingham Palace is pleased to confirm
that the Duke of Sussex will attend the
coronation service at Westminster Abbey
on the 6th of May the Duchess of Sussex
will remain in California with Prince
Archie and Princess lilabelt
um so we're getting that's the latest
bit of information and that was the bit
of information that most people wanted
to know will Harry be coming to his
father's coronation but we've got a bit
more information about what's going to
happen it's will soon be upon us May the
6th and what we know is that the king
and queen consort will travel to the
coronation actually what you're looking
at are pictures of Harry when he was
last in the UK it was um he was here to
hear a case against
um the media that he he wasn't him in
particular that was bringing that case
but it was a group of people and that
was the last time we saw Harry who went
back to California we didn't know he was
going to be here and now we've got
confirmation confirmation that he will
be here on May the 6th Buckingham Palace
saying that he will be here but Megan
The Duchess of Sussex will stay in
California with Prince Archie and
Princess Elizabeth so the kids will stay
at home with their mum